- The only thing scarier
than being haunted by a
ghost is getting sued.
And you may not believe in ghosts,
but that doesn't mean that
they don't show up in lawsuits.
(people screaming)
(ghosts laughing)
- Oh my God!
The Scoleri Brothers!
- Because telling ghost stories
isn't just something that
you do around a campfire
or as an overused plot
device in horror movies.
- Why, once I met this
guy who knew this guy
who knew this guy who knew this guy
who knew this guy who knew this guy..
- In fact, ghosts have actually
repeatedly been involved
in litigation.
- We would have to perform a sue-ance.
(lightning strikes)
(spooky ambient music)
- And when it comes to
the paranormal in court,
judges don't simply say ghosts aren't real
and get that (bleep) outta my courtroom.
Judges have repeatedly treated spirits
with a veneer of seriousness
in both civil and criminal cases.
And on occasion, poltergeists
have even helped establish
legal precedent that we
still teach law students
to this day.
So let's start with the ghost
who testified from the dead
to convict her own murderer.
In July 1897, Edward Trout Shoe
was convicted of first degree murder
by a Greenbrier County West Virginia jury
in the strangling death
of his wife, Zona Shoe.
What makes this gruesome murder so notable
is the evidence that
sealed Mr. Shoe's fate
came from a most surprising source,
the ghost of his murdered wife.
This was the first and
to date only instance
in the US history that
testimony of a ghost
has been admitted as evidence
to obtain a conviction.
So how did this ghost help
convict her own killer?
Well, it's quite the story.
On the morning of January 23rd, 1897
the 23-yeah- old Zona Shoe was discovered
by an errand boy sent to
the house by Trout Shoe.
The boy found her at
the foot of the stairs,
face down, dead, her
head cocked to one side.
By the time the coroner arrived,
Trout had moved his
wife's body to their bed
where he had dressed her in
a scarf and high necked gown.
Trout was sobbing uncontrollably
and showed signs of distress
whenever the corner attempted
to examine the body.
Now, out of respect for
the grieving spouse,
the coroner stopped
his cursory examination
and then wrote in his
report that Zona died
of quote "everlasting
faint," or heart attack.
At Zona's wake the next
day, attendants noticed
more odd behavior from Trout.
When the casket was opened for viewing,
Trout immediately covered
Zona's neck with a scarf
and propped her head with
a pillow and blanket.
Trout also put on a display
of inconsolable grief,
blocking mourners from
getting close enough
to look at the body.
Then one month later while Zona's mother
lay wide awake at night,
Zona's spirit appeared before her mother
to reveal a shocking truth
that Zona was murdered
and Trout was her killer.
Zona's mother then went
to the local prosecutor
to reveal what she had learned
from her daughter's ghost.
Over a period of four nights,
Zona's ghost purportedly appeared
and gave a chilling account of her murder.
Zona's spirit revealed
that Trout had a history
of physically abusing her.
When Trout became enraged
one night that Zona didn't
serve meat for dinner,
he grabbed his wife by the
throat, crushed her windpipe,
and snapped her neck between
the first and second vertebrae.
After hearing this, the
prosecutor went to the coroner
to ask what he had
observed about Zona's neck.
When the coroner revealed the husband
had prevented him from examining the neck,
the body was exhumed and a
second autopsy was performed.
They found bruises on Zona's
neck in the shape of fingers,
a crushed windpipe, and her neck broken
between the first and second vertebrae,
matching the mother's account
from the daughter's ghost.
And in the course of investigating,
the prosecutor discovered that
Shoe was not who he seemed.
Edward Trout Shoe was
actually Erasmus Shoe,
a blacksmith from a neighboring county.
Shoe also had a history of violence
and was married twice before.
His first wife got a divorce
after enduring physical abuse,
while his second wife died
under mysterious circumstances
after eight months of marriage.
But after Trout was charged with a murder,
there were real concerns
about securing the conviction.
While Zona's neck was broken
and there were hand marks,
there wasn't much hard evidence
linking Trout to the crime.
The prosecutor was reluctant
to subpoena Zona's mother,
fearing her ghost story
would actually damage the case,
but instead of discrediting the witness,
it appears that it actually bolstered
the prosecution's case.
Here's an excerpt from
the remarkable exchange.
"Mrs. Heaster, are you positively sure
that these visits are not for dreams?"
"Yes, sir.
It was not a dream.
I don't dream when I'm
wide awake, to be sure,
and I know I saw her right there with me."
"Are you not considerably superstitious?"
"No, sir, I'm not.
I was never that way
before and am not now."
"Now, I would like to say if I could,
to get you to say that
these were four dreams
and not four visions or appearances
of your daughter in flesh and blood."
"I'm not going to say that
for I'm not going to lie."
So pro tip, for all you aspiring
trial lawyers out there,
don't tell the witness
you're cross examining
what you want them to admit,
because they're probably
not going to do that.
Ultimately, the jury convicted Trout
with just over an hour of deliberation.
He was sentenced to life, which ended up
only being three years
when he died in prison.
But that brings us to the medium
who faced an extra large copyright lawsuit
after claiming that Mark
Twain's ghost wrote her book.
Because at the turn of the 20th century,
America was in the midst
of a craze of spiritualism.
During this time, the
practice of holding seances
and seeking guidance through mediums
became increasingly popular
in the United States.
So when St. Louis medium
Emily Grand Hutchings
claimed that her new book,
"Jap Herron" subtitled
"A Novel Written From the Ouija Board,"
was actually authored
by Mark Twain's ghost
as revealed to her by the Ouija board,
many Americans bought the book
believing Hutchings' claims.
Among those skeptical of
the book's ghostly origins,
Mark Twain's Estate and Twain's publisher
who were so offended by the claims
they went straight to court
seeking to block publication
and have every copy of the book destroyed.
It all started in September, 1917
when the book got national attention
following a scathing review
from the New York Times.
Panning the book as quote,
"a feeble attempted imitation
of Twain's humor," the reviewer cast out
on its ghostly origins by
noting the recent trend
of dead authors allegedly writing books
through Ouija boards.
Quote, "if this is the best
that 'Mark Twain' can do
by reaching across the barrier,
the army of admirers that
his works have won for him
will all hope that he will
hereafter respect that boundary."
In June, 1918, Mark Twain's estate
through his daughter, Clara Clemons,
and Twain's publisher,
Harper and Brothers,
went to the US Supreme Court
to file an extra large copyright suit
against the medium and her
publisher, Mitchell Kennerley.
The complete alleged Harper and Brothers
held the exclusive right to
Twain's stories for 17 years.
And Hutchings and Mitchell Kennerley
were infringing on that right.
The complaint asserts
that quote "'Jap Herron'
is far below the grade of
anything Mark Twain wrote
while alive and the
circulation of the book
would harm his reputation."
The complaint further
alleged that Hutchings
approached Harpers with a book in 1916,
but Twain's publisher refused
to publish it on quote,
"the ground that it didn't
emanate from Mark Twain
and had no literary merit."
For relief, plaintiffs requested
that the Supreme Court blocked
publication of the book,
have all copies destroyed,
and require full accounting of
all illegally earned profits.
However, the plaintiff's
victory was by no means assured.
To establish copyright infringement,
they'd have to prove
definitively that a ghost
spoke through a Ouija board,
which was no easy task.
And as the New York Times
reported at the time,
quote, "there is of
course ground for doubt
whether testimony transmitted
through a Ouija board
will be accepted.
The court may consider it
incompetent, irrelevant, and immaterial."
And as kind of amazing the
kind of hedging of bets
that the New York Times was
doing with the word 'may'
in that particular sentence.
But anyway, the plaintiffs here put forth
a clever two-step legal strategy
to corner the defendants.
On the one hand, if Twain's ghost
did actually write the book,
the defendants have committed
copyright infringement
and must return all profits
made to Twain's estate and publisher.
On the other hand, the mediums
could avoid a copyright claim
by simply admitting that Twain's ghost
didn't actually write the book,
which would expose them as liars.
So stuck between the rock of
massive copyright exposure
and the hard place of
admitting to be frauds,
the mediums agreed to halt
publication of the book
and remove all copies from stores.
The copyright trial of the
century would never come to pass,
but Hutchings would continue to insist
that she was telling the
truth until her death in 1960.
Though Mark Twain famously
quipped, "if you tell the truth
you don't have to remember anything."
So whether Hutchings was
a liar with a great memory
or an unjustly mocked prophet,
I suppose we'll never know.
(girl screams)
Ooh!
But that takes us to a
couple of ghostly cases
coming out of Texas.
They say that everything's
bigger in Texas,
but you know what else is bigger in Texas?
Cases where people took
financial advice from ghosts
only to claim fraud when
the advice didn't pan out.
You know, that old chestnut.
Because in the early 1900s,
Texas courts addressed the issue
of ghostly misrepresentation
in both civil and criminal contexts.
In the case of Burchill versus Hermsmeyer,
Bell Burchill claimed ghosts told her
that there was substantial
oil under her land.
- I drink your milkshake!
- Believing this to be true, HC Hermsmeyer
invested $10,000, about
$175,000 in today's dollars,
into Burchill's oil company.
When no oil was found, Hermsmeyer sued
to recover his investment,
arguing that Burch's claim
constituted a fraudulent
misrepresentation of fact.
But the Texas Court of Appeals disagreed,
ruling that ghosts cannot form the basis
of a fraudulent misrepresentation,
because the existence or
non-existence of ghosts
is uncertain and a matter
of belief, not fact.
And a similar result
occurred in the criminal case
of Nurse versus State.
Jim Nurse, a self-described spiritualist,
claimed that he could speak to ghosts
who told him a large amount of money
was buried under the property
of one Mr. Alexander.
- I've heavily invested in gold,
which I've buried in
several different locations
around Pawnee.
Or have I?
- After someone working
on Mr. Alexander's home
found money buried by
the house's foundation,
nurse advised Alexander to
rebury the money immediately,
because otherwise the
spirits would vanish it all.
Nurse allegedly returned
later to dig up the money.
Nurse was swiftly arrested
and convicted of the crime
of swindling, the early
20th century term for fraud.
Now, the state argued
nurse was a charlatan
who fraudulently induced
Alexander to part with his money
by falsely claiming he
could talk to ghosts.
But like Burchill, the court of appeals
threw out the conviction on the grounds
that whether or not
Nurse can talk to ghosts
is an unknowable fact that cannot serve
as the basis for a fraud claim.
Quote, "there is no evidence
in regard to the matter
one way or the other that
is as to whether or not
appellant conversed with the spirits
or called them up and
tested their veracity."
Ultimately, the court concluded
that Alexander was neither
deceived nor misled
because the alleged fraudulent claims
that money was buried
under Alexander's house
was actually true.
And since the underlying claim was true,
whether Nurse could talk to
ghosts was legally irrelevant
and Nurse's swindling
conviction was reversed.
But that takes us to the
house that was haunted
as a matter of law.
Now, one of my favorite
Halloween traditions growing up
was watching "The Simpsons"
Treehouse of Horror episodes.
I still remember the very
first Treehouse segment,
"Bad Dreamhouse," where
the Simpsons family
is horrified to discover the
mansion that they just bought
is haunted and actively
trying to murder them.
Now, obviously, this
is just a silly cartoon
and no one would ever
try to actually get out
of a real estate purchase
because the seller didn't mention
that the house was haunted, right?
Well, this actually happened
and it was successful.
And this opinion, which is
taught in every law school
in the country, wasn't handed
down a hundred years ago
during America's spiritualism
craze, but in 1991,
less than one year after
the Simpsons episode aired.
Yet another example of the
Simpsons predicting the future.
- As you know, we've inherited
quite a budget crunch
from President Trump.
- So here's the story of America's
first legally haunted house.
Jeffrey and Patricia Stanbovsky
were a New York City couple
who decided to leave behind the big city
and move slightly upstate to
the village of Nyack, New York.
While looking for a new
home, the Stanbovskys
fell in love with an
eight bedroom, 4.5 bath
Victorian mansion occupied
by George and Helen Ackley
and their four kids.
Mr. Stanbovsky agreed to buy
the property for $650,000
with a $32,500 down payment.
So what's the problem here?
Well, the sellers neglected to mention
that the house had a
decades long reputation
for being haunted.
A reputation that the Ackleys
themselves helped cultivate
by talking it up in the
local and national press.
In the 1977 Readers Digest article,
"Our Haunted House on the Hudson,"
the Ackleys recounted the
family's many ghost interactions
in the home.
Most notably husband George claims
he saw a pair of disembodied
moccasin clad feet
walk up the stairs while Helen claims
that she saw a man in a powdered wig
and Revolutionary War attire.
The house was even a feature
on a walking tour of Nyack
and periodically attracted
paranormal enthusiasts.
Now, after learning about
this previously undisclosed
ghostly history,
Mr. Stanbovsky filed
suit seeking rescission
of the real estate contract.
But the trial court
dismissed Stanbovsky claims,
citing caveat emptor.
Caveat emptor, Latin for
let the buyer beware,
imposes a duty on a buyer
to reasonably examine
the fitness and value of
property before purchase.
And under this principle,
a buyer is barred
from rescinding a contract
on the basis of defects
that would've been discovered
through a reasonable investigation.
But Stanbovsky appealed this decision
and the court of appeals
reversed the trial court,
reasoning that because
the sellers themselves
were the source of the
home's haunted reputation
and this fact that
materially impaired the value
of the property could
not easily be discovered
by even a diligent buyer,
the failure to disclose
was grounds to cancel the agreement.
Quote, "whether the source
of the spectral apparition
seen by defendant seller are
parapsychic or psychogenic,
having reported their presence
in both a national publication,
(Reader's Digest) and the local press
(in 1977 and 1982, respectively),
defendant is stopped to
deny their existence,
and as a matter of law,
the house is haunted."
(spooky music)
So what happened next?
Well, the Stanbovskys were
able to back out of the deal,
but don't worry, the
Ackleys had no problem
reselling the house.
Since then, the house has
changed hands multiple times
being most recently sold in
March, 2021 for $1.8 million.
And in 2002, New York
replaced caveat emptor
with an affirmative duty to disclose.
Sellers are now required to fill out
a standard form disclosure statement,
containing 48 affirmative representations
about the condition of the property.
Though sadly, zero
disclosures about ghosts.
And there haven't been any hauntings
since the accolades left,
which some paranormal investigators
attributed to the ghost being
bored of the new owners.
Now, if you like Ghost Law
want more scary law stories,
you should listen to John
Grisham's new legal thriller,
"The Judge's List" on
today's sponsor, Audible.
It's all about a judge who
is also a serial killer
and uses the law against
his investigators,
because a killer who
knows how to manipulate
the legal system is the
scariest killer of all.
Woo!
I use Audible almost every day.
It's by far the best source
of audio entertainment.
I listen to audiobook when
I'm running, cleaning up,
or when I'm supposed to be listening
to friends and loved ones.
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
all in one place.
If you tried to listen to everything,
it would take you three centuries.
As an Audible member, you'll
get one credit every month
that you can use on any title
in the entire premium catalog.
That includes basically every bestseller,
new release, or memoir.
These titles are yours to keep forever
in your Audible library.
And then you also get access
to their Popular Plus catalog
which is filled with thousands
and thousands of audiobooks,
original entertainment,
guided fitness and meditation,
sleep tracks, and other shows.
All are included with your
membership, no credits needed.
Now, right now audible's
running a special promo.
New Audible members get
a free one month trial.
You can try it out and
see why I love Audible.
All you have to do is go
to audible.com/legaleagle
or click on the link
that's on screen right now
or down in the description.
So right now, for a limited time,
get a free one month trial of Audible
by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now
or down in the description.
After that, click on this link over here
for more Legal Eagle, or
I'll see you in court.